All right, here is my work from home
office. So, I have my IKEA desk over
there with my PS5, my mechanical
keyboard, uh Logitech MX Master Mouse. I
got my little uh bullet journal where
where I like to draw funnels all day
long so I can sell stuff, which is
really really cool. And then, uh MacBook
Pro, got my PlayStation Breakthrough
Advertising Legendary, okay? And then,
to the left of my desk is my personal
study. It's my library. It's all the
books that I've been collecting for a
long time. All the Russell Brunson
stuff, the Ben Settle stuff,
Robert Greene, great copywriting books
over here, fiction novels,
my Bibles, self-help kind of stuff.
Really, really good library. And then
over here, past the French doors, is my
guitar corner. So, I do
play guitar. I played guitar since I was
about 7 years old. My uh pedal board and
amp and I got a strat, Gibson Les Paul,
Gretsch Black Falcon, and then the
Eastman acoustic uh over there. And then
over right next to it is kind of like my
my chill reading corner. So, this is
where, you know, I'll do my uh morning
quiet time. I'll read a copywriting
book. I'll read some fiction novels. And
then right there to the left is my
putting green.
I do sometimes putt during Zoom meetings
or whatever if I got to hop on a call
with somebody, but I love to play golf
on the weekends, and so I like to
practice my putting. And then this is
where I record my videos, right there.
You know, I'll just put my phone right
there and enjoy. So, that is my office
just for you. Private video that's going
on the internet for everybody to see.
Enjoy.